clearly very comfortable not nervous at
all for anything no super comfortable
and relaxed
hi guys I'm here with Steve Zaragoza
he's so exciting we just recorded a
podcast that was Omega fun so you guys
should go over on soundcloud or itunes
and listen to nacho deep with grace
Helbig and my guest Steve and we talked
about a lot of really culturally
important things
yes we got we are Applebee's Steve is
being a huge team player right now
because I've asked him to stay to do a
the bean boozled challenge with me which
you've done before I have done it before
I think we're gonna play it in a way
that I didn't play it the first time
okay
we were definitely just spinning them
out oh he's really just like taste
testing then we were tasting them and
going bros norm the way this works is
there are a sort man of seemingly
delicious jelly beans here however
there's a possibility that some of them
are actually terrible flavors yeah for
instance the black ones could be
licorice or skunk spray oh that that's a
very specific way I know what it smells
like almost that tastes like and why
would you stop just spray up so what's
gonna happen is we're gonna go back and
forth spinning the little spinner here
and then both of us will have to select
a jelly bean based on the color that we
land on if we are unable to eat the
jelly bean we must spin again yes so we
have to spit it out we have a spit Cup
yeah which is strangely exactly like our
drink so if we have to spin it out
because it's so gross we have to
instantly spin again and do another one
yes and so the first person to spit out
three jelly beans loses
as a hospitable host I will let you spin
first oh that's so sweet of yeah thank
you you're out throwing me to the wolves
first yep Oh God all right here we go
I'm gonna spin it well okay well let me
try to get my fingers out of the way
there okay there we go
what is it it's right in the middle of
spin so anticlimactic or anticlimactic
again right in the middle okay there we
go this is you
I'll get lime or lawn clippings so we
both we both choose a green Betty Cheers
I honestly can't help I can't either cuz
it's silly I was like this is lawn click
then they got Pleasant wait a minute
there's another green oh I think we took
the wrong green when do Zuma gram juicy
pear or booger Oh juicy pear Sam I think
yeah mine's juicy pear all right okay it
is we could end up getting all delicious
flavors I actually don't know oh now it
could be buggers yeah it's got a weird
aftertaste all right well I mean will
you ate it so successfully yours yeah
yeah
god damn it is out of there Adam okay Oh
when's that color peach or barf peach or
barf oh my god peach or barf 50/50
chance is gonna be a peach or barf [ __ ]
peach its peach haha oh thank Christ
it's peach this is a great game to teach
kids to develop their flavor palate
because I normally don't like peach but
in comparison to but is the most
delicious flavor I've ever ate all day
instead of bar all right let's see oh
gosh chocolate pudding or canned dog
food Oh Cheers coming up please be
chocolate pudding mine dog food yep my
dog just
oh right salt so this is gray spit it
you ever spin again and eat another one
right now oh my god I don't have to
participate in this cuz she swallowed
her or didn't swallow it coconut or baby
wipes out so bad all right here we go
coconut or baby wipes coconut Oh YUM I
think wait I took a turn I didn't like
it baby why was the changing one baby
one oh it's bad the worst thing about
jelly beans is it's like you think that
once it's real bad you could just
swallow it but you can't you have to
keep get stuck as you're getting some of
your teas on my turn again
yes that was my punishment it was your
punishment Jesus again licorice or skunk
spray brush or skunk snicker is also
just not a flavor I enjoy betting on
skunk spray never this is lose-lose for
me
alrights black licorice or skunk spray
licorice no gross oh so gross so gross
but it's so pretty great well you are
brave I have to I don't want to go I
don't want yeah okay all right back to
chocolate pudding or canned dog food oh
my god cheers Cheers
chocolate pudding mind choco pudding as
well here we go oh
butter popcorn or rotten egg all right
grace good luck butter popcorn or rotten
egg no no no I gotta get through this oh
oh oh I got buttered popcorn grace I
just I don't even know it's time that
was real bad I'm sorry for you oh no
Peter barber judge is not good that
stuff don't Egyptians are not nothing
Gibson they're gonna turn to everything
I've taken a jerk oh my god ah oh
Barba's oh hey barks worsen rotten egg
Oh rotten egg or buttered this again but
this is my punishment that's your
punishment and love it this is rotten
egg Mike sighing okay Cheers
so tomorrow you spit out those you have
to keep going no I have a three I spit
out three I lost well I still need to
take my punishment so let's take it fair
and square
juicy pear or booger juicy pear or
booger yeah it's booger
I gotta tough it out oh you are oh my
god this is the definition of man oh my
god like salty and these are the best
chips I've ever had I feel like we have
sufficiently been bean boozled I think
so too but I think there was somebody
didn't try like we didn't try the
toothpaste so let's try the two things
what is it it's just blue one here what
is the option I see they're gonna be
toothpaste or berry blue or berry blue
okay 250 either is really that bad
toothpaste
actually very refreshing and needed
right now I was at base two actually
very delightful and then this is gonna
either be tutti frutti or stinky socks
no cheers Cheers
tutti frutti tutti frutti oh thank god
okay you know what I got a stop right
there I want to go out on a high note
are you sure because caramel corn or
moldy cheese is still uh I'm out really
I'm going for oh my god I can't actually
tell what that is
oh it's moldy oh oh it's timed it just
doesn't happen right away how are they
coming up with these flavors like and
like how are you mixing them and then
yeah what kind of like board meeting or
they have a what I like I suggest like
sweaty ball sack right yeah or and then
who's the guy that's like tasting one
and going like that's not quite bar a
little more tomato in it
they gotta be getting paid I hope they
got well do you thank you so much for
subjecting yourself to this torture yeah
I don't know if I should be thanking you
for inviting me to this yeah I mean good
friends exploit each other it's true
thank you being a good friend and maker
vehicle you guys go check out Steve over
on his channel and on SourceFed and go
over to iTunes and SoundCloud to listen
to the whole podcast that we recorded it
was really really fun yeah much more fun
than this yeah way more fun at least for
us yeah this might have been fun for you
castles fun too
yeah I don't know like would you know
somebody's called the old coleslaw
Factory
I don't think I would eat at the
coleslaw okay yeah oh what's that was
the old casserole factory come on down
to the old panini palace yeah no I don't
want you in an old place